i am so happy and grateful for the
donations
at just the age of nine jordan banks was
doing all he could
to help save lives but the boy who's
been described
as the life and soul of the party was
killed
in the most unlucky circumstances his
family said
yesterday our world stopped we lost the
brightest star
our beautiful boy jordan his laugh that
infectious smile
golden curls he was our everything
wise beyond his years caring considerate
generous and so loving our love is
endless
good night beautiful boy lightning
cracked over the seaside town of
blackpool
as jordan was playing football a sport
he loved
today friends family and even those who
didn't know jordan
came to pay tribute i started crying
straight away
soon as i heard it because my very best
friend in my
class at school so sad
just to see it all see where he like he
was playing on there
i just feel one word heartbroken that's
just how i feel
he was um kind he was he was he was
always happy
he was always smiling he would just
never give up with tackling
the club that usually uses these playing
fields
cancelled their training night because
of the violent thunderstorms
but nine-year-old jordan continued with
his private coaching session
despite the horrific weather
hi jordan how's it going um i've heard
that you're doing an amazing thing in
raising funds
it was only recently liverpool player
james milner congratulated jordan for
his fundraising efforts
and today he was remembered by his
school as a lovely bubbly pupil
but above all as a kid who cared for so
many
jordan was the life and soul of the
party a very fun
loving young lad loved life
raised money for charity himself and
enjoyed his football
enjoyed running enjoy and enjoyed
all different aspects of life some here
are asking why a training session
was allowed to continue during the bad
weather but this is a community clearly
hurting
after the tragic loss of a boy who gave
so much
in term rasheed sky news blackpool